okay
I'm Amplified it's always nice to be
Amplified hello people with Microsoft
hololens headsets on are you having a
good time
are you turning me into Daffy Duck
um yeah so hi welcome to the end of NDC
Oslo 2023 have you had a good time
I'm going to take that as a no try again
have you had a good time
thank you
okay so the next time you can interact
with the NDC crew and all these great
speakers that you've seen is that the
Copenhagen developers Festival in August
which is a new thing that they're trying
so this is going to be during that we've
got some workshops going on there uh
we've got talks during the day and then
in the evening they bring out the beer
and the barbecue and the bands and we've
got proper music stages and sound
systems and the whole thing
um but you can come along to that you
can bring your family there's stuff uh
in the evenings for kids to do you can
bring your kids and they can go and do
gaming sessions and all kinds of mad
stuff uh you can find out about that at
cphdevfest.com and
uh you will be able to see these
fantastic speakers these are the
speakers who were above the fold on the
Copenhagen developer Festival home page
and that's um I'm sad so I'm just gonna
stick myself on there as well
screw you guys
but the really good news is that because
you have come to and paid for NDC Oslo
2023 you can get 50 off your ticket for
the Copenhagen developer Festival you
just need to email info
ndccconferences.com and they will tell
you how you can get that 50 discount on
your Copenhagen ticket so do that come
it's gonna be great I'm going to be
playing bass on a proper stage I've been
playing bass for like all of seven
months and I'm going to be playing bass
uh live on stage I'm kind of excited and
Heather will be singing
and uh Dylan and and people and and then
other actual proper bands and everything
okay we've got some prizes to hand out
uh so we got two of the Raffles from the
conference that we're gonna draw now and
so first up we have uh Cloud works and
so if you'd like to come up on stage and
here's the microphone say a few words
please give it up for um
hey everyone
so here Cloud Works uh we do all things
identity experts in both competency and
systems
we had a challenge for anyone stopping
by our booth to go hunting for white
rabbits both here at the conference and
on the internet with a total of 13
rabbits each with a little bit of a
web token to uh to collect and deliver
to us
a complete token gave an entry into the
raffle
not too many were able to complete this
but this is of course uh a star on your
LinkedIn page is completing our
challenge
so perhaps you Mark can do the owners of
uh picking one for the record he has not
entered
the winner is Johan Henning Lawson
[Applause]
uh prize was a collection of cloudworks
merchandise but probably the most
significant thing there is a pair of
Apple airpods
unsure if their clockwork's branded but
they should be in my opinion yeah thank
you
thank you very much Round of Applause
I should have entered I want some
airpods okay so next up we have the if
there is a representative here uh we
have Vonage is a there he is Vonage are
giving away the Batman tumbler I didn't
enter this because I actually got this
for Christmas and that is such an
awesome model uh that is really really
fun to build so do you want to say a few
words
uh so I am
known as the representative from Vonage
uh my name is also Benjamin I'm a
developer advocate of Vonage if you
didn't have a chance to stop by the
booth
um Vonage what we do is we Empower
developers through our communication
apis uh so why reinvent the wheel every
time you need to build out SMS or Voice
or video or authentication Solutions
think of Vonage
um so we are giving away this amazing
Batman tumbler and Mark do you remember
the theme song from Batman
yeah I don't know why you're playing
bass you should be in the front man
uh so I think what we're gonna do is
let's all try to do the theme song from
Batman no no no no no no no no no no no
no no wait we're all gonna do it
together and then I'm gonna announce the
winner
sorry one two three four no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
Yannick live from DN V
Yannick are you here
[Applause]
he is yeah congratulations
have fun checking that into your luggage
good luck okay thank you very much
Benjamin
[Applause]
and with that we get to move on to my
latest attempts at one of these weird
lock note things
um we I was just over at a table over
there and we were using chat GPT to
generate the abstract for next year's
lock note uh which is going to be uh the
life and death of Tamagotchi is there a
digital afterlife or something along
those lines
um I'm just gonna you know chat GPT
writes the abstract I use uh what's the
thing stable diffusion to generate the
slides and then just get up there and
talk for 60 Minutes easy
okay so this is how JavaScript happened
a brief history of programming languages
this is the first time I've done this
one it's a work in progress uh uh there
will be a lot of Corrections by the time
I do it again at Copenhagen because
it'll go up on YouTube and if you want
people to correct you then put yourself
up on YouTube Works fantastically
but it is necessarily brief I'm not
going to dig in some of your favorite
programming languages won't be there and
yes how JavaScript happened is supposed
to come with that subtext of and how can
we stop it happening again
so in the before times before there was
programming and before there were
computers
you want to talk about programming you
kind of have to start with Ada Lovelace
the first programmer so Charles Babbage
uh went to the UK Parliament and got a
million pounds which was a lot of money
in those days these days it'll buy you a
potato given the UK economy at the
moment but he went and he said I'm going
to build a Difference Engine and they
went here's a million pounds go away and
build the Difference Engine so we went
off and he got about halfway through and
then he got bored and had a better idea
uh so he went back and went give me two
million pounds I'm going to build an
analytical engine and they went no but
he designed the analytical engine and
Aida Lovelace
Byron's daughter so Lord Byron of the
laudanum and syphilis and hanging out
with Shelley and generally causing
trouble this was his daughter and uh she
essentially invented a programming
language for the analytical engine and
then wrote a program in it to calculate
Bernoulli numbers whatever the hell
those are and that was in the late 19th
century and then nothing happened for
about 60 70 years and then this man came
along Ellen Turing
so Alan Turing is kind of the The
Godfather of programming and programmers
and Alan Turing he was a mathematician
but he came up with the idea for the
Turing uh machine the infinite State
machine and you feed paper into it and
it can rewrite the paper and he proved
mathematically that that could solve any
problem and then the second world war
started and the Nazis were communicating
using uh the Enigma machines and we had
no idea what they were saying and then
some Polish people captured a U-Boat and
captured the Enigma machine off the
U-Boat and then uh Alan Turing went to
Bletchley Park in the UK and he built
the bomb
um which was actually also a polish
design trying to give as much credit as
possible where it belongs to in in this
talk
um and they built this and this cracked
the Enigma code and so we could
understand what the Germans were saying
this was not a computer this was a
machine and it just chunked through all
the possible combinations of enigma
wheels and patch cables and everything
until it spat out what the current day's
encryption code was
and then the Germans used this this is
the lorentz cipher machine
which is much more complicated and
there's many more permutations and so
cheering and a guy called Tommy flowers
who worked for the post office
um built Colossus which was a bigger and
more complicated computer that was
intended to crack the Lorenz Cipher and
it did and it worked but it still worked
in roughly the same way
and so as with so many things the
computers and the world that we have
today actually came out of this horrible
conflict that that happened in the
middle of the 20th century and one of
the problems that they had
uh in in America in particular Americans
don't like getting up close and fighting
they like sort of throwing things at you
from as far away as possible and so they
wanted to say if I throw this thing that
weighs this this hard how far will it go
and where will it land and will it be
close enough no I'm not going to go
there that's that's just bad
um
and so they built eniac the electronic
numerical integrator and computer
and the word computer actually when they
were building eniac that was a job title
that was computers were usually women
and they would just add up big tables
full of numbers and do multiplications
and all this sort of thing and come out
with the answer and so they built eniac
and eniac you didn't program it using a
programming language you programmed it
using cables and you linked this cable
over to this thing and it was like a
switchboard like one of the old
switchboards that you see in black and
white movies and they're just linking
things together to link different logic
blocks together and the people who built
any act hadn't bothered to document any
of this stuff and so the people who
programmed imiac essentially just
figured it out they figured out what
each of the different things did and
then they put the cables in and they
worked out the missile trajectory tables
or whatever it might be these are the
names of the eniac programmers uh six of
them all women in
okay
and I'm just looking out now and yeah
where did you all go
so yeah hi all sitting down at the front
but no programming so building the
hardware building any Act was considered
to be man's work and uh programming it
like actually putting in the things to
make it do anything was considered to be
women's work
um and so for a while we had these
computers that you just configured to do
a single job and then you turned it on
and it ran for a bit and it spat out the
answer and then you turned it off again
um and that actually took us quite a
long way into the middle of the 1950s
the sort of early 50s Maybe
and then IBM released the IBM 701
and this was marketed as a calculator
this was not a computer this was a
calculator and it was huge and they used
this for the same thing I mean they used
it for lots of things it was used for
science it was used for research it was
used to calculate the explosive
detonation range of nuclear bombs and
all sorts of stuff but basically you
took a very simple trajectory formula
like this one where y equals X10
Theta oh minus G to the X to the 2 to V
cos two Theta yeah I don't understand
maths I have no idea I just never did
maths Beyond GCSE but you had to take
these formulas and then you had to turn
it in to machine code because the 701
was one of the first sort of proper
commercially available stored program
computers you could put a program in
just kind of digitally and then run it
and these are the op codes these are the
ways that you told the CPU in the IBM
701 and you say CPU we think of that
these days as the little chip that sits
in the middle the CPU in those days was
the entire room and these were the op
codes that you would use and so you
would have to work out how to translate
that formula into those OP codes to get
the right thing out and then you would
literally use some little switches and
set them on or off to the binary thing
here and then push a button to load it
into the machine and then do the next
one and push the button and it would go
into the machine and if you made a
mistake you turn the machine off and
start it again and that was how
programming was done
okay so IBM followed up the 701 with the
and I mean this this was an absolutely
enormous computer
no
that's not actually an IBM 704 that's a
model of an IBM 704 you can go and uh
find out about it at that web address
it's it's it's exquisite
um and while they were building the 704
before they started selling it they
hired a guy uh called John Backus John W
Bacchus
and John Backus he'd done some
mathematics he done some engineering
he'd done some science and some physics
and that sort of stuff
um and he got a job he was wandering
down the street in Manhattan one day and
he looked through the window and IBM had
the very first 704 kind of on display so
people could see the flashing lights and
it actually had more flashing light the
flashing lights were added they didn't
do anything they were marketing IBM just
thought people will stop and look if
it's got flashing lights and John Backer
saw the flashing lights and went in and
said oh what is it what's this for and
they told him and he went can I be a
programmer and they went well go
upstairs and interview and so we went
upstairs and interviewed and someone
said yeah why not and so he became a
programmer because yeah why not
um but the important thing about John
Backus the thing that changed the world
about John Backus is that he was a lazy
lazy bastard
okay
Bill Gates allegedly said I choose a
lazy person to do a hard job because a
lazy person will find an easy way to do
it
and I honestly as a lazy person myself
the effort I will put in to not doing
something
it's insane I will happily work an
entire weekend without sleep and just
coffee just not to have to do something
that would probably take five minutes
just on the off chance that I might have
to do it again next week
um so yeah and so John Backus looked at
the formulas and then he looked at the
machine code and he just worked at the
formulas again and then just
I'm not doing this for the rest of my
life
I think I can write a program
that will translate the formulas
into the machine code a formula
translator if you will
and with immense naming inventiveness he
called it Fortran
and it gives you and I this was like the
wild west days because this was IBM
right this was the in two and a half
years we will deliver you a spec and a
project plan company and John Backer
says I want to make a programming
language and they said what's a
programming language and he said I'm not
sure
but it's gonna be good
can I build it and they went yes and he
went can I have some people to help me
build it and they went yes and they gave
him some people and this was 1957 this
was the year Sputnik one launched okay
um and actually the orbits of Sputnik
one's final stage uh was calculated as
one of the first programs run on an IBM
704 that told them where the Sputnik
stage one was going to come down it's
also
um where Sputnik 2 launched in the same
year with Leica on board my went for
Leica
that'll do
so yes so Fortran was created by John
Backus
um and these other people Goldberg best
Herrick Sheridan Nutt Nelson Zilla Stern
height and Sarah and this is all of them
uh most of them some of them but yep
that was a sort of meeting uh they went
away and they just hid in in a room in
IBM and then IBM said we need this room
go to that building and so then they
went to that building for a while and
they rented hotel rooms down the side
there and they invented something that
had never existed before they invented
the programming language this talk is
actually quite heavy on Fortran because
when you're talking about how did
JavaScript happen you start with how did
programming generally happen and Fortran
was the start and so we I'm going to
talk about Fortran possibly a little bit
more than the others but yeah they went
in there and there there was a lot of
stompery
um at that time see if this sounds
familiar at all
um the people who were doing machine
code programming the people who knew and
actually had memorized that big table of
binary numbers and it got really good at
flicking them and putting them in the
machine and everything else
they went oh no
a programming will never be able to
write machine code as well as I can
write machine code
I mean we've all kind of thought that
ourselves at some point
um and so Backus and his team their
mission was to prove them wrong and
actually to demonstrate that their
programming language would generate
better machine code than most
programmers could create manually so in
a sense Fortran right from the start the
very first programming language to
machine code compiler was already an
optimizing compiler and you know these
days you look at clang or GCC or
whatever the machine code that it
generates it's stuff that a human
assembler programmer would probably
never write but it works because that's
that's how machines work they just go I
know this will work it may look ugly I
promise you this is faster
okay so we're going to use fizzbuzz a
lot through the course of this
presentation this is fizzbuzz in Fortran
so if you don't know what Fizz Buzz is
then you failed the interview
um
but no so fizzbuzz is actually a
children's game you sit round in a
circle and you go one two and then if
the number can be divided by three you
say Fizz but if you can be divided by
five you say buzz and if it can be
divided by three and five or to put it
another way fifteen uh then you say
fizzbuzz
you see a one two Fizz for Buzz
uh five phase six seven no seven eight
but anyway
I I can't do that either it's been a
very long week
okay so in Fortran uh we say program
fizzbuzz and then we say do uh 40
I equals one comma twenty so this says
Loop
and uh set I to one and then go
incrementally up to 20 one at a time uh
and then when you get down to 40 do
what's there and then from 40 you will
come back up to here so I've done talks
in the past where I've mentioned into
Kell so intercal is a a made up a
ridiculous programming language and it
doesn't have go-to it has come from that
40 in that line of Fortran there is
essentially a come from that's kind of
going this is where the loop ends
Fortran used line numbers but you only
actually needed to put line numbers in
if you were either using them as part of
a do Loop like that or if you wanted to
go to them so it wasn't like basic where
every line had a number it was just
these are essentially we're naming this
line except we just gave it a number
um and then we just go so if uh mod this
then print and then that 8h fizz Buzz
that's how you say put the next uh this
number of characters out as text and so
it will print Fizz and then we continue
which jumps down to 40 and then goes
back up there but we've got the if mod
does not equal zero then 15 doesn't go
to doesn't equal zero go to twenty
otherwise print Fizz buzz and continue
then if mod 5 doesn't equal zero then go
to 30 otherwise print buzz and mod 3
print visit go to 40 and then 40 will
either Loop background or it will print
the number
okay
okay so fun things about this
Fortran had two variable types integer
and real
because it was for Science and
trajectories and that sort of stuff and
so they didn't need dates and times and
all the sort of data types that we take
for granted these days they didn't
actually need Char so Char was just int
um and so when you put Fizz buzz in
there the Fortran compiler actually
during the compile process turned those
into the integer codes for each of those
characters
it didn't have a way of declaring the
type of the variable in the very first
couple of versions of Fortran 57 and 60.
so if a variable started with i j k l m
or n it was an integer
otherwise it was real
um and so when you did Loops in Fortran
you've defaulted to well what's the
simplest thing I can call an integer
variable I
and as far as I can tell this is why
even now in JavaScript and every other
programming language in the world we say
four let I equal zero I is less than
whatever I plus plus it dates back to
Fortran where we used I because that was
an integer we couldn't use a because
that was real and if you added God knows
what would have happened to it
if you try to Loop based on a reel
okay
now Fortran
the way it worked
um this just makes me absolutely
terrified you Fortran came on Punch
Cards eventually uh or fairly quickly
because of the number of punts cards
that the Fortran program took up they
switched to using tape and so you would
load a tape into the machine but the
very first and all the time they were
building it and testing it so they wrote
Fortran in machine code and then dumped
that machine code out onto Punch Cards
um so you would feed the Punch Cards
into the IBM 704
and then you would wait for it to sort
of go yep I'm ready and then you would
feed the Punch Cards containing your
Fortran program
into the hopper and it would go through
all of those and then it would either
give you an error code saying
850 cards and there was an error on
number 849 go away
um and you would feed those in and if
your program was correct it would
compile it and then it would dump your
compiled program out on more Punch Cards
over at the side there and you pick
those up from the output Hopper and you
would go back to the start here and then
you would turn the machine off and on
again to zero out the memory and then
you would feed your compiled program in
and it would run and you would get the
output
that was programming in 1957. and so
every time I hear people go oh we need
to optimize the inner loop I kind of go
yeah you really don't know you were born
unless you are a JavaScript programmer
and you have to do npm installs on
GitHub actions public instances in which
case yeah fair play this probably takes
longer
um the the hilarious thing here so every
single one of those cards is one line of
code each column on that card is one
character and there are uh 80 columns
and so you needed the first six were for
the line number and kind of spacing and
so the longest a Fortran command could
be was 74 characters and so whatever you
were doing uh in a single operation you
had to fit it into 74 characters and
they used to draw these lines or draw
things on the side of the deck of cards
because if they got into the wrong order
you were essentially just screwed that
was it I have no idea how to put this
back in the right order so um yeah spare
a thought for the Fortran programmers
this is factorial in Fortran it's
actually very simple n equals one do ten
I equals one uh n obviously can be an
integer i j k l m n so we say n equals
one and then we do this Loop uh to 10 n
equals n times I and continue and then
print n
so that will do factorial nine
um
now n times I all the time they were
building Fortran they just used the
times character because they weren't
particularly bothered about what
characters they had available to them
and IBM hadn't finalized the character
set that was going to be available on
the 704 and then when it came time to
actually sort of start preparing this
for release IBM went what's that and
they said that's the time symbol and IBM
said we don't have that
and they went
how are you going to do multiplication
and IBM went I don't know
and so they had to find another
character to use for multiply and so
they chose asterisk
so asterisk became multiply and again
that's just it it's weird you know when
you were a kid and you first learned
programming and you go how do you do
multiplication and you type
21x2 when the computer goes now that
doesn't make any sense and you go how do
you do multiplication someone goes use
the star
because you don't know what an asterisk
is when you're eight and so you go which
is the star shift seven I can't really
remember where the
shift eight
um I don't look at the keyboard when I
type
so yeah so that's uh Fortran introduced
the idea of using the asterisk for
um for the multiplication symbol and so
Fortran I mean if you boil it down for
each of these languages we're just going
to go what is there in JavaScript that
came from this language so Fortran it's
I've kind of got these three items but
also the abstract concept of a
programming language and the importance
of that cannot be overestimated and I
give a lot of credit to John Backus
um and it's an indicator of what an
amazing job that small team of people
did being shunted around various IBM
offices in the 1950s that
people still use Fortran today you can
go to Intel's website and download the
Fortran compiler optimized for the
latest Intel CPUs and the SSE
instruction sets were implemented in
Fortran before they ever made it into C
or C plus plus or any other programming
language Fortran is still used
scientists in particular love it and it
still generates the fastest code of any
high-level language compiler out there
so good job John and everybody
so yeah
but then
this chap came along this is Edgar
Dykstra I have no idea if I'm
pronouncing that right and he wrote a
paper around the time of fortran's
release he looked at Fortran and he
wrote a very famous paper and submitted
it to some Journal called go to
considered harmful
he did not like go-to Fortran that was
the only way you had of doing control
flow you had ifs and you had go-to's you
had do and it would jump back up to
there but if you wanted to say oh go
down here and do this and you didn't
have subroutines you didn't have gosab
you didn't have functions or procedures
or any of this sort of stuff and
dijkstra did not like that incidentally
while I've been doing the research for
this and more research for this talk
than anything I've ever done in my life
I think I'm writing a book
um
I did see the 4i equals for J equals for
k equals uh there is a an urban legend
that it comes from the ijk in dijkstra's
name as bollocks it's for Trans integers
but yeah so Edgar Dykstra over his
career he said a lot of things for
example he said computer science is no
more about computers than astronomy is
about telescopes which is kind of deep I
like that
um he said this which I really like if
debugging is the process of removing
bugs then programming must be the
process of putting them in
yeah I I think that probably is a good
definition for the programmer but he
also said some things that may be not so
good programming in basic causes brain
damage
um also not a fan of COBOL uh for
similar reasons he just really didn't
like basic and and COBOL and anything
really I think
um but his go-to considered harmful his
point was that programming languages
should be structured and we should
organize our code in better ways and we
should have rather than having line
numbers and go to and then go to back
again and this sort of thing we should
have uh blocks of code with structure
and we should have named procedures or
subroutines or addresses that we could
jump to and then that name would become
part of the code and so his ideas were
adopted by the algol team so algol in
the same way that uh formula translation
became Fortran algol was the algorithmic
language
and algol Fortran was Bacchus and his
mates and a shifting team of people over
time and they were sitting in the room
and they were building it and they were
designing it and they were testing it
all at the same time algol uh the second
programming language was designed by a
committee
um quite a lot of it in Paris and so
they came up with a language that to be
fair for something designed by a
committee it's not bad
um the first
two or three versions didn't have IO
because apparently there was nobody from
printer companies on the committee also
I don't know
um but it's it's still pretty good and
it got a lot of these ideas right so
that's the the people who were on the um
algol committee and you'll see on there
that you've got Bacchus so he was
brought in on there we've also got
McCarthy we'll come back to him in a
minute
um and we'll stop nor
um and so you've got Bacchus and no and
you sort of think
why does that sound familiar so the
grammar that we still use today to
describe programming languages BNF
Backus nor form so the first iteration
of that was actually called Backus
normal form and it was done just by John
Backus and he created it just to
describe our goal so that it was a way
that the algol committee could sort of
write down what kind of like open API
and yaml files but for programming
languages sorry that was a call back to
my talk earlier on
um
and then nor kind of worked with him and
improved it for a second version and I
think it was actually Dykstra who went
oh you should call it Backus noriform uh
and so yeah BNF still use that today so
this is fizzbuzz in algol
um and you can see a couple of things
here so we have a begin and an end and a
four and an end uh and an if and an L if
and an elif and an else
um and so we've got more structure
coming in here and we have no line
numbers we also have type declarations
so we say integer I before we start
using it so we're not sort of just going
if it starts with this letter then it's
this and oh yeah so we declare what that
is
um and then uh we had a few things in
algol algol is probably
um you've got Fortran
the idea of programming and a couple of
things but in terms of actual stuff that
went into later modern programming
languages our goal was probably the most
influential one most languages have kind
of adopted things from algol
um so yes we have semicolons at the end
of lines uh some lines not other lines
so that's very typical we don't put it
after a a then for example we don't put
a colon after it either white space was
insignificant in algol whereas it was
quite significant in Fortran
um not very significant it's kind of
chaotic but it did it did uh those first
six characters if they weren't there
your program was good
um so yeah
um but we have an if and an elephant and
all this sort of stuff and so uh there's
there's things are starting to appear
here that you sort of think that's I I
use a programming language today that
still looks a bit like that
um so yeah uh
essentially our goal gave us the idea of
block structure it gave us the idea of
if then else uh which Fortran didn't
really have Fortran had if go to if go
to if go to if go to and just jump on
and do things
um algo the very first version of
alcohol actually had switch uh built
into it so if you wanted to check
something against multiple values it had
switch it had four Loops it had
functions you could declare functions
um it had semicolons at the end of the
lines and it had Bacchus norform as the
way of formally describing it's grammar
um and so yeah uh algol gave rise to
various other languages which we'll look
at as we go along
so
this
speaking of algol is Tony Hawk or C
Antony horse sir C Anthony or fellow of
the Royal Society and various other
things and he worked on an algol
derivative called algol W that had
records and references and so he added
he sort of came up with the idea for
those things in algol W and that was the
first thing that had records and had
references to other records within
records and all this sort of stuff and
so the thing that algol W has
contributed to JavaScript is of course
null
um
but you know where would we be without
null probably on Mars
okay
this guy who just looks like you know if
I ended up back in 1955 and I needed to
charge my time machine and get it back
to the future I would go looking for
John McCarthy this is the man so John
McCarthy worked at MIT and he worked in
the AI Lab at MIT with Marvin Minsky who
we have since discovered to be an
extremely problematic individual but
John McCarthy as far as we can tell just
decent stand up Luke and he had he
learned Fortran and he kind of went well
it's fine for the science stuff and and
that kind of thing but I'm dealing more
with artificial intelligence I'm trying
to prove that computers can think like
human beings can think because I have
sorely underestimated how complicated
thinking is
um but you know
and he figured that the way we think is
lists and we have lists of stuff and we
prioritize things in lists and then the
thing that's at the top of the list is
the most important thing and so on and
so forth and so he created a language
for list processing
called lisp
as opposed to lip which is for Lift
proper thing
sure if that's unacceptable is that like
like mocking people now or something I
don't know
anyway so yes
so lisp has anyone programmed in lisp or
scheme or closure yeah so quite a few
people yeah we've got any list
programmers sitting behind the stage
you're going no we're waiting for the
next conference to start we don't know
who you are
um
but no so lisp uh
uh very interesting language if you've
programmed in lisp
um somebody call out for me what is the
uh the operation name to get the
atom of the start of a list
car
what is the operation to get the
remainder of that list
why
nobody knows okay
so
lisp John McCarthy implemented lisp on
the IBM 704 now
one of the other things that's really
wild about uh computers prior to I can't
remember when it was but we didn't have
bytes and kilobytes nobody had decided
that eight bits was going to be a bite
and that we were going to work in
multiples of eight and so the IBM 704 it
had the concept of a word so a unit of
data that the CPU could do something
with which was 36 bits
um
probably something to do with the way
the memory system was made or something
like that but it had 36-bit words and
the way it was divided up for op codes
was you used the first three bits of the
first half were a tag a prefix tag and
then 15 bits was the address of the item
in memory and then you had another three
bit prefix and then the second part was
the index of the item to work on which
was actually calculated starting at the
top of the memory and now starting at
the bottom memory I'm working up so it's
called a decrement register okay so the
first half was the address register
and the second half was the decrement
register and when John McCarthy
implemented lisp he needed linked lists
and the best you know if you implement a
linked list in the simplest way possible
it's a single thing which contains
the I the current item
and then a pointer to the next value in
the list which will contain item number
two and then a pointer and so that's how
he implemented lists and so car is
contents of the address register and
Cuda is contents of the decrement
register
technically it's the address part of the
register and the decrement part of the
register if anybody out there on hello
YouTube is going to try and correct me
on that because it's like there was 15
bits that any other sort of stuff but
yeah he called it car and Coulda because
it was the content of the address
register content of the decrement
register and now
70 years later
we are still using car and Cuda for
these operations in lisp and you're just
kind of like yeah that is that's an
implementation detail bleeding through
into the design that's probably the best
example I've ever seen of that I had no
idea like I say until I started
researching this I did not know that so
yes
lisp by John McCarthy
um this is Carr and Cuda so Carl will
give you Kirsty and Cuda will give you
jack Jacobs Steiner and Henriette and
I'm sorry if I couldn't fit anybody else
on there this is fizzbuzz in lisp so we
Define a function Fizz buzz and we say
Loop for n from one below 101 do let
divisible by three so this is the Mad
thing about lisp
it's data structures and the language
are the same thing so it's just it's as
really really simple it's basically lots
of round parentheses and lists of stuff
and those lists can be data or they can
be operations or they can be input to
operations and you can put lists inside
other lists and it's it's just
absolutely nuts and so to implement this
we talked so we had a linked list
so he had pointers to things going on in
memory and so to get this to work he had
to implement the Heap so our goal and
Fortran both just used essentially a
working chunk of memory but it wasn't a
heap as such lisp he had to implement a
heap he had to implement an allocator
when you create a list it will allocate
some memory and assign it to that list
and so he also if you wanted your
program to keep running for any length
of time uh had to have a garbage
collector and so this very first version
of lisp running on the IBM 704 in 1958
already had a garbage collector John
McCarthy didn't write it I can't
remember the name of the dude who did
but somebody wrote it for him
um and the other thing is because it's
so flexible you can do tortured things
with lisp you can do really really hairy
things and I don't think it was intended
as a design feature but he inadvertently
invented first class functions because
if a function is a list and you can put
a list in a list then you can put a
function in a list and if you can pass a
list to a function and that List's got a
function in it then you invented first
class functions you've invented
functional programming and so list was
the first functional programming
language and so from lisp we get
functional programming and first class
functions and we get the Heap and
garbage collection and we're still in
the 1950s it's absolutely bonkers
and we really need to speed up this talk
needs some editing okay so I'm going to
whiz through the rest of this quite
quickly because I've got what 10 minutes
um so similar it does actually get quite
quick from now on because it's really
not a lot left to invent
um so similar oh Lay Your Hand dial and
Kristen Nygaard at the Norwegian
Computing Center in Oslo yes objects
oriented programming was invented here
in Oslo Round of Applause for them
so this is fizzbuzz in simula and we
have a class and we have refs and we
have this sort of uh this stuff going on
here we have procedures inside classes
um so simula was created to literally to
create simulation code and the point
that they had is if I want to simulate
multiple bodies interacting in a system
then wouldn't it be great if I could
wrap each of those bodies up as as a
self-contained thing and then just see
how it interacts with other things and
so object oriented programming actually
came out of this desire to simulate
multiple things interacting within a
system and so we've got lots of stuff
from simula we've got classes
inheritance polymorphism and scope as
well the idea of having private
protected internal whatever your
different scope options are in your
programming language of choice so
similar lots of people think Small Talk
was the first object-oriented
programming language it wasn't it was
similar it took some ideas from weird
things people had done with our goal and
obviously our goal W with its records
but simula was the first object-oriented
language
then Along Came Kenneth Iverson I love
Kenneth
um he was a teacher he was teaching
programming and he wanted a language
just for teaching programming and so he
created APL which stands for a
programming language
apparently he was also really good at
Cash invalidation
um
so yeah he created APL here he is
drawing on a Blackboard
oh dear it's been a long week
um
this is fizzbuzz in APL
it's it's an insane language okay
um it had a lot of weird Greek symbols
and stuff in it but fizzbuzz the the
cool thing about APL is when you do an
operation you can say do it on all the
elements of this array at the same time
and so it can do Bonkers things there
are people these days they work in
finance and they use an APL derived
language uh that I can't remember the
name of it's k or something like that
um and uh when they write their high
frequency trading algorithms to go and
be evil in Wall Street
um they use an APL derived language to
do that you think this is bad right
that's fizzbuzz obviously fizzbuzz has
to contain fizzbuzz Fizz and Buzz in
there for it to work so the the useful
bit of it is contained in about eight
characters at the end there
that is actually Conway's Game of Life
in its entirety in APL
that's the whole program
it's just insane the most insane thing
about it is that this is the keyboard
um if you're one of these people who
builds their own mechanical keyboards
you can order APL keycaps for it and
then you can download EPL and you can
actually programming it like that but
the thing that APL actually introduced
that nothing had done before was Dynamic
typing so if you declare a variable in
APL it's an array of stuff and you can
set an element in that array to be
whatever the hell you like you can set
it to be real and then next time around
you can say now it's an integer next
time around you can say now it's a
character so APL gave us Dynamic typing
which obviously JavaScript picked up and
ran with uh along with some scissors
okay
so going back to our goal the next sort
of series of things that came out of
algol were bcpl
um or it's no CPL then bcpl and then b
um so bcpl batch control processing
language created by Martin Richards
here's Martin Richards he was at
Cambridge University and he created bcpl
which was derived from algol but made a
little bit easier to work with and you
can see here that we've got a Ferrari
equals 1 to 100 do it basically looks a
lot like algol he got rid of the
semicolons he didn't like the semicolons
and somebody else bought them back but
the one thing that he had was this idea
of libraries so at this stage by the
time we got to
um this
era the 1960s we had terminals we had
storage you could have libraries just on
the disk and then you could import them
and so bcpl introduced this idea of
saying import a library for me
and bcpl was the first language that
used curly braces uh for denoting blocks
instead of begin and end didn't use them
for all stuff so test still had then on
the end he didn't sort of figure that
one out problem was that Curly braces
weren't in a seven bit ASCII and most
things in those days were using 7-bit
ASCII and so you could substitute the
curly braces for Dollar open paren and
Dollar close paren and that would work
just as well but if you had curly braces
available to you you could use curly
braces so bcpl gets those
then Ken Thompson created B Ken Thompson
was a dude in the 19 late 60s and and
the 70s Ken Thompson along with Dennis
Ritchie and uh kernaghan created the
Unix operating system
um here is uh Ken Thompson there on the
right with Dennis Ritchie
um just hardcore programming dudes at
Bell Laboratories uh in the 1970s uh Ken
Thompson so B inspired C which Dennis
Ritchie wrote
um but never really made it as a
language on its own
um but Ken Thompson obviously also
created Unix along with some other
people he personally individually
created Ed which was the Forerunner to
VI if you think VI is hard try editing
text with Ed a line at a time uh grep
was a personal utility that he wrote for
himself until someone went Ken that
would be really useful can you share it
and he copied it into slash bin and then
he went away for a bit and then in the
naughties he turned up at Google and
helped design go
so yes so B didn't really lead to much
except C so Dennis Ritchie created C and
when I was a junior programmer and you
wanted you turned up to work and they
said learn a useful programming language
because all I knew was Amiga basic and
they went here Blue Book learn that and
you learn C and you learned how to write
hello world first uh hello world example
as a way of writing code so that was the
C program that's where hello world comes
from
um but C we have curly braces we have
the include we have semicolons we have
all that good stuff and so that is
fizzbuzz in C now one of the things we
all know about C is that you can do some
very interesting things with it so there
you go that's also fizzbuzz in C
um but the main thing that c added
brought to the world so before c went
bcpl and B and all this sort of stuff we
were still saying for I equals one to
ten do this sort of thing C introduce
this idea of the three statement for
Loop so four initialize the variable uh
test the variable do something to the
variable so that came from C
then in 1972 as well uh Small Talk came
along so small talk uh came out was
written by Alan Kay and Dan Ingalls and
Adele Goldberg and it came out of uh
Palo Alto Research Center or Xerox Park
and small talk was kind of the second
object-oriented language except Alan Kay
has often said I wish I hadn't called it
object oriented I wish I'd called it
message oriented programming because
that was much more the point but he
didn't and so here we are thanks
um but Small Talk worked really well
with the other thing that was being
invented at Xerox park at the time which
was the idea of the GUI of uh
of a programming environment and
application environment where things
didn't happen one after the other and
you had to respond to events and this
idea of objects that passed messages
between each other and responded to them
fit very well with that idea of
um the the graphical user interface so
just for fun here is uh Fizz buzz in
small talk
um and uh it's it's weird if you've ever
done Objective C uh that took quite a
lot from small talk I used to say in a
different talk The Objective C took the
best parts of C plus plus and the best
parts of small talk and threw them away
foreign
so the funky thing with small talk that
you see in JavaScript as well is integer
was defined in the system runtime but
you could extend it
um at in your own code so I'm going to
add a fizzbuzz function to the integer
type I'm going to tell the integer how
to respond to a fizzbuzz message and
here it is this will do it
um and so yeah the other thing that came
and this is from Wikipedia
um everything in small talk is an object
classes are objects a class is an
instance of a meta class which is also
an object everything's an object it's
objects all the way down floating around
in space on the back of four objects on
the back of a much larger object and
just hurtling towards Oblivion
um and code blocks which has Anonymous
functions are also objects but it also
introduced the idea of anonymous
functions okay so small talk gave us
lots of things small talk had a virtual
machine that it ran on so it created an
environment for your code to run in that
meant it could have reflection and it
meant they could build a bunch of tools
into that environment including
something like a console so a debug area
and this idea of everything being an
object
so small talk then we have ml ml machine
language this was an sort of evolution
of functional programming uh this is
fizzbuzz in ml and the main thing that
came from ml that went into JavaScript
is the arrow function the Lambda thing
there so Arrow function syntax then we
get a scheme scheme was a variant of
list but much simpler variant of lisp
that was created at uh MIT by Sussman
and Steele to support their cs601 course
on programming scheme there's nothing
really from scheme that wasn't in lisp
that has made it in the main reason it's
in the presentation is because
JavaScript was originally implemented as
a scheme and then it was only when Java
sort of started to rise in popularity
that Netscape went Brendan make it look
like Java and he went ah it's finished
so yes
uh that's Fizz buzz in scheme it's
essentially a simpler and nicer version
of lisp then we got C plus plus by Bjorn
strausstrap so shout out to any Danish
people
both of them
you thought there were more of you
didn't you
so yeah Beyond Strauss drop uh basically
went RC's not complicated enough
that's this this is actually a quote
from him C makes it easy to shoot
yourself in the foot C plus plus makes
it harder but when you do it blows your
whole leg off
um so this is Fizz buzzing C plus plus
the main thing that we got from C plus
plus so languages had had exceptions and
exceptional behavior and that sort of
stuff before C plus plus was the first
thing that called it try catch and throw
um and had the concept of a typed error
so you could catch different types of
error in order so that came from C plus
but right back to algol you had the
ability to kind of raise an error
condition you couldn't deal with it
anywhere it just set some lights up on
the on the machine but um yeah that was
that who's ever heard of a programming
language called self
yeah no me either until I there is the
programming language called self apart
from anything else my God that's hard to
Google
programming self here's some python
um
so yeah but no self was created by David
Unger and Randall Smith it was kind of a
small talkie sort of thing but instead
of classes it had this new idea of how
to do object-oriented programming based
on prototypes so you wouldn't have a
class you'd have a prototype and then
when you wanted to create an instance
you just copy that prototype sound
familiar yeah
um it's still people are still making it
there's like a self 2017 on their
website or something
um I could not find fizzbuzz himself
like I say really hard to Google but
this is what it's object-oriented thing
looked like so animal is an empty object
and then dog is an object where the
parent is animal and so is cat and then
lab is an object where the parent is dog
and so forth so self is where the idea
of prototype based object orientation
came from although they kind of were
inspired by the thing on doing
object-oriented programming in scheme
from sicp and if you want to know how
that works read the damn book but yeah
they've got a website latest version 27
18.1 download now no
so then of course there was Java Java
was created by James Gosling at Sun in
the uh 90s and the first use of java was
to create applets that you embedded in
your web page and when you wanted to
make it so that when they put the mouse
over a button the background color
changed you wrote a goddamn Java applet
and you did weird things with RGB
um and so this was how we got the idea
that web pages could be interactive in
the first place this is I mean this
isn't a realistic implementation of
fizzbuzz in Java because there's no Fizz
Factory no buzz Factory and no fizzbuzz
Factory manager
um
but it's something like that
okay and then we got JavaScript and
JavaScript has been inspired by all
these different things taken these ideas
from all these different places and has
congealed them together in one Unholy
mess
that I regret deeply and you know time
machines Hitler maybe Mussolini I
wouldn't kill Brendan Ike I I would
honestly no I have nothing against
Brendan Ike
um I would just sort of go to Netscape
maybe like six months before they asked
him to build it and I would say Brendan
in six months time they're going to ask
you to throw together a quick
programming language uh to like as a
demo feature for Netscape Navigator 2.0
just a heads up in 2023 it's going to be
the most widely used programming
language in the world
please can you put integers in it
so yeah
again I've been thrown by things while
researching this so many times Netscape
Navigator of course it came in a box
because you couldn't go on the internet
to download it because you didn't have a
web browser there's there's the boots
that you had to go to like Best Buy or
or wherever and like buy a copy of
Netscape Navigator on multiple floppy
disks and take it back and install it on
Windows 95 it was mad
um so yes now there is one addendum to
this which I'm going to throw in there
because there's a lot of net people here
and so there was another language which
was inspired by C plus plus which was C
sharp hmm
no okay it was inspired by Java
and uh that was Anders halesberg these
days it's maintained by mads Torgerson
um and a whole bunch of people super
smart people my favorite programming
language and I've used a lot and it's
still my favorite and I still love what
they're doing to it uh this is fizzbuzz
in modern C plus plus where we're just
doing horrible switchy things and
pattern matching and so we can create a
tuple with the modulus N3 and modulus N5
and then switch against that Tuple and
do multi-value things and my time is up
so C sharp the main thing that's gone
from C sharp into JavaScript was async
and oh wait and so that is how we get
from Fortran to JavaScript I'll time it
better next time honorable mentions
there's all the programming languages
that didn't make it into this talk and I
swear to God that actually was all of
them
um one last note if I've been mean about
any languages this is flon's Axiom there
does not now nor will there ever exist a
programming language in which it is the
least bit hard to write bad program
so take that with you out into the world
thank you very much for coming and
staying for my little talk at the end
and thank you to everybody at NDC thank
you Kirsty for starting this whole thing
Jacob for organizing things Henry at
Heather Steiner Magnus all those people
thank you all the technical people who
do the sound and the video screens and
everything else thank you the Caterers
and the serving staff who've been
keeping us fed and watered for all this
time thank you to all the sponsors that
mean our tickets cost less than ten
thousand dollars each and thank you all
for coming and making this conference
what it is maybe see you in Copenhagen
if not maybe see you back here next year
thank you